Hello my name is zachary levi i should have a
little tag and i play shazam we all established
something very special on the first movie and
in shazam theory of the gods we expand on that
now they have to balance their
life with being superheroes
this is where you hang out with
your superhero friends isn't it
these goddesses come to our world our incredible
new villains lucy lou and helen mirren
she's kick-asses calypso we have mythological
creatures minotaurs harpies and dragons when
i talk about upgrades we got an upgrade huge
upgrade in the suit bigger action sequences
bigger set pieces we go from athens
to philadelphia we go from the rock
of eternity and the library of eternity
to the realm of the gods so we get to go
to environments that were never explored in
the first phone we have it all three two one
shazam fury of the gods
takes the excitement and the action to a whole
new level it's going to be more of a spectacle
it's fun all around you're
in store for a treat y'all
Why is it so dark probably would have
been a good idea to have like one light on
Welcome back everyone this will be my video
for the shazam 2 teaser trailer they release
fury of the gods there's obviously a bunch of new
characters and new mythology they're weaving into
this is huge so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos also explain how this ties in
with what's going on in the black adam movie in
the future of the shazam vs black adam films that
they have planned and if it wasn't clear all this
is happening in the dceu on the same earth that
the justice league snyder cut took place on so
this is all canon each of the black adam movie is
taking place over in the middle east in khandaq
and this is taking place in philadelphia but the
big thing that they're teasing in the movie here
is that this is basically them versus the gods
that they get their powers from so the fury of
the gods is the fury of the gods they get their
powers from the name shazam is an acronym it's the
wisdom of solomon the strength of hercules the
stamina of atlus the power of zeus the courage
of achilles in the speed of mercury so in the
movie the gods that they're fighting here even
though there are only two that you see they're
technically three gods three sisters that they're
facing and they're the daughters of the titan
atlas so when the shazami is wielding the power
of atlas when their powers were activated they
essentially took that power from these sisters
father and you actually see atlas in the realm
of the gods there's a statue of him holding the
earth on his shoulders helen mirren is playing
hespera lucy liu is playing her younger sister
kalypso in rachel ziegler we don't know her name
but she's also wearing like this bright gold godly
armor so even though they show you some footage
of her talking to freddie freeman looking like
a young beautiful girl she's just also one of
their younger sisters pretending to be a normal
person when she meets freddie freeman here it's
just that her sisters played by helen mirren and
lucy liu are the ones that you see doing most
of the damage in all the footage if you're not
familiar with greek mythology the titan atlas
actually had seven daughters mythologically
that is they're referred to as the pleiades and
they represent a constellation in the night sky
you see a mixture of behind the scenes footage the
new shazam family costumes the way they've changed
the rock of eternity and obviously some of the
big fight scenes but the staff that you see them
looking at here huspera and kalypso lucy lou and
helen mirren's characters is the same staff that
belong to the wizard shazam that they broke
during the first movie that's why it's in two
pieces because billy batson broke it in half after
he shared his power with the rest of the family
but it seems like it still holds a lot of power
and is one of the big macguffins of the film
the gods want the staff back for some reason and
it might be so that they can take the power of
their father the titan atlas back from the shazam
family so it's like the shazam family effectively
stole the power of the gods to power themselves
up you see footage of rachel ziegler's character
talking to freddy freeman on the rooftop of their
school you also see some exteriors of that later
in the trailer too the way they're playing
this it sounds like there's going to be some
sort of romance between their characters like she
meets him pretending to be a normal girl and he
kind of falls in love with her because in this
later footage here you see hespera and kalypso
her sisters rachel ziegler's sisters show up and
grab freddy freeman and take him back to the realm
of the gods you can see him here kind of freaking
out in the background here inside their temple
but because you see so much of rachel ziegler in
her gold god costume clearly they're going to play
it for a big reveal on the movie there's even a
scene that looks like her protecting him before
he's activated his powers or maybe he can't
activate his powers at this point in the film
because like i said if they're trying to take the
powers of the titan atlas back take some of the
powers of the shazam family back then either
they'd be significantly weaker or they just
full-on lose their ability to transform also the
other really big thing in this trailer you notice
is they're bringing the wizard shazam back jaime
hansu's character but he actually kind of looks
like a younger version of the character and if
you remember he actually died during the events of
the first film so either they're bringing him back
from across time and space or they're bringing him
back from the realm of the dead because remember
this is all playing on greek mythology so there is
hades there is an underworld there is a realm of
the dead somehow they bring him back because you
see him standing here with the rest of the shazam
family before they transform like all of them
in present day standing in front of this parking
garage all the mythological creatures and monsters
that they tease for the show and then show off
here this first one is the chimera the second
one is the cyclops even though they talk about
minotaurs they'll just be minotaurs in it as well
these are the harpies and then they say they'll
be full blown dragons like you see billy batson
later in the trailer fighting a dragon they're
filming a scene of him fighting a dragon with a
bunch of special effects this is his giant tail
these soldiers in the gold animalistic armor
are just the gods minions like you see one of them
bring part of the staff of eternity to one of them
the scenes they talk about in athens that they
show you here are just amongst the ruins of the
gods ancient temples there might be flashbacks
to ancient greece when the gods reign supreme
and i know a lot of you are asking about wonder
woman crossover because wonder woman and the
shazam characters kind of share a pantheon of gods
but by present day in the wonder woman canon most
of the gods have been killed off so we'll see how
they reference that because there are a couple
other wonder woman easter eggs during this footage
like when they show you the inside of the rock of
eternity the shazam family has redecorated
it to make it look like their living room
like a childhood fantasy lair if you were a little
kid and you wanted to make your own bat cave what
would it look like it looked something like this
they have a little shrine to the justice league
there's wonder woman in the flash over here on the
right i don't know if that implies that they're
both going to cameo during this movie they did say
they wanted to get a wonder woman cameo they've
also decorated over all the seven deadly sins
in comedic ways like they drew a bikini on one
they made a joke about gluttony starting to eat
kale they've even decorated all the thrones like
i said it's basically a childhood fantasy lair
like if you told a bunch of children they could
do anything that they wanted to with their room
this is what it would look like then when they
show you the inside of the library of eternity
it's a different part of the rock of eternity
with them just staring at this magical artifact
is meant to contain the sum total of all magical
knowledge like an infinite library on everything
magic then the temple on the mountaintop is the
realm of the gods so to speak the gods that are
still alive so the greek titan atlas here the
statue behind them hespera and kalypso seem like
they rule here and obviously their sister rachel
ziegler like i said i think the reason they're
doing that is just to play it for a big reveal
during the movie early theory like they make you
think that she's just a normal girl but then some
big action scene happens and you find out that
she's nearly indestructible and super powerful
just like her sisters because so much of this
movie is playing on the idea of the greek titans
in their battle with the gods and what happened
to create the shazam character like where did the
wizard shazam get all of his power from in this
staff how did he steal the power of the titan
atlas they might do some flashbacks like the first
wonder woman movie did or even the justice league
snyder cut with the big dark side war flashback
where they gave you this giant tutorial on the
origin of the gods themselves they show off more
of the fight scenes which seem way more epic than
the ones in the first film then they just focus on
each of the new characters in their new costumes
basically saying during the events of this film
the shazam family has effectively learned to
balance their normal lives and their superhero
lives the other big thing here is that we have
grace fulton the person who played young mary
marvel is now also playing the powered up version
of her character just because she'd aged up in
real life and looked like she could pull it off
the way that zachary levi explained the black
atom crossover because we just got that big black
atom trailer when are they actually gonna fight
each other both he and the rock said that they
basically have a plan to eventually do a crossover
movie but it won't happen until after shazam 2 and
after the first black adam film so it might wind
up being shazam 3 they could do it as a separate
film and then do shazam 3 as something completely
different but they're in the same universe you
could make the comparison to spider-man with tom
holland and tom hardy's venom character crossing
over so spider-man versus venom required a little
bit of multiverse travel they don't have to do
that during the shazam and black atom crossovers
but there's a bunch more dc fandome footage and
trailers i'll try to do videos for all that stuff
really soon eternals is coming out pretty soon too
and i believe the review embargo is up so my
eternals review will post on sunday look out
for that make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss anything everyone
click here for that black adam trailer video and
click here for the batman trailer video in easter
eggs too thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!